it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it right
[Music]
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kid
we're out come on baby
let's [ __ ] go yeah we're good to go
let's go bro
you look like a piece of candy not in a
bad way but you're colorful as [ __ ] and
i'm a little jealous a little toucan
well this toucan gets a big b what's
that guy you got some big beak on the
toucan sand you got you got i like pink
i like pink that's a hot pink on one arm
this is a fuchsia or some [ __ ] on the
other hand
oh that's what it is that's in san diego
now let me tell you about san diego yeah
unless i haven't been down there but
pre-pandemical is pretty crazy yeah and
that's pando you know it's not as crazy
sure but san diego yeah during comic con
daddy been down there it is not so the
kids say it's lit
liddy but i really like it i'd say it's
a little too crowded for me
yes stresses me out well i'm an old man
so what happens to me is you'll never
see me in a parade you're not going to
see me in a lot of crowds because i just
worry about
all the things that can go wrong even if
i didn't worry about i probably wouldn't
be at a parade no i don't know but i
thought comic-con was like for the like
younger kids yeah yeah
grow men in outfits my man grown men and
outfits sir and they have money because
these outfits are lit you don't outgrow
nerdum ner nerd nerd
that thing's a big deal so so my dad's
i know a guy he's an older man
and uh he was probably 60 at the time
and he goes he made a lot of money and
he's going to go back to his high school
in this brand new porsche to show all
like your reunion yeah or just like a
random like
no no he's six periods
hey kids
no he's a 60 year old man he goes i'm
going back
to my high school reunion in a porsche
to show all those kids who made fun of
me that i
made it and i'm cool now now ready he
shows up in his porsche it's a porsche
like it's one of the ones you like the
with the fin very expensive and all that
he goes the extra mile
and he
my my
dad said how'd it go
and he said um
you know what i realized and he goes
what he goes i'm just a nerd with a
porsche
yeah i don't know if
you really think that he'd pull up and
what even if it was a bugatti like his
old alumni would like dude you oh my god
you're so much cooler
so much hotter now if he
created bugatti and hand built that car
and pulled up then then you've achieved
something if you're elon musk you you
are you are cool because if you you ever
seen pictures of him before he got the
whole hair oh yes yes yeah and jeff
bezos
tough thanks all of them now steve job's
the only decent one right now coolest
guy on the [ __ ] planet
yeah there you go
yeah he's really steps now again if
you're elon musk and you're bullied in
high school and you want to flex on them
and you have whatever your chopper land
in the middle of the [ __ ] auditorium
you're like what's up yeah oh oh you
guys are staying here what throughout
the night we'll have to take off because
we're trying to get to mars have a good
day
i i want i'm trying to set up a pig hunt
when i'm in austin this weekend
i want to i i this is weird but i do
want to shoot them from a helicopter
with a machine gun you know what you you
want to know what i think you should do
what kill it with your hands
so
you can wear kevlar pants
this is
you can wear kevlar pants yeah and i
think a kevlar like overalls or
something
and then you can try to kill them with a
spear
yeah i want you to do with your hands
like a gun
so the only way to do it with your hands
is how do you know
the throat
okay but how do you how do you how do
you get them you can't just do dogs yeah
you get your cat's dogs get your cat's
socks yeah i just feel like that's
i don't want to do it because it makes
me sad our boy cody but shooting him out
of a helicopter with an automatic
machine gun doesn't make you think i
feel like they die faster and they're
vermin so that's why you have to kill
them it's not that i wanna it's the only
animal i feel like i'm helping the
environment if i [ __ ] hey
but you can't do with your bare hands
see to me let's be sad but that's more
you know it makes me like i feel like a
little bit like a like a serial killer
no i feel like a false warrior when i do
that like dogs are holding it down then
i come in you know but out of a man-made
helicopter with a machine gun
yeah but i mean it's not like you're
but i feel like if you're okay here's
the thing if you want to cut a pig's
throat yeah i do there's only one reason
you're doing that what is it to eat no
it's so you can feel what it's like to
cut a man's throat that's what you're
doing no no right no that's the easiest
way to put him out of his misery no i
know but for being a bore but you're
right
because
there are there are there are people
that are so boring that probably they
should they should be have their
but if you they should be but i just
feel like you'd be more intriguing like
your episode i bet would you get your
highest views ever if it's you
with a knife and the cover is you blood
but faith you take the from the kill
take the blood upon your face yes it's
all over when you're like a knife
shirtless yes and then i get trichinosis
or some [ __ ] because the blood has all
these parasites in it maybe i know but i
feel like that'd be worse than just
watching you shoot him out of a
helicopter i shot it you know hard to
see me see them as well right well i
shot a deer one time and we did it with
this girl i had a crush on
and uh my buddy said the native
americans would drink the blood we have
to say a prayer so he said a prayer then
you you cut the throat and you drain the
blood and then what you do so it doesn't
coagulate is you mix it with a little
vodka and then the girl just took it and
just went goose drank it and blood was
savage and i was like this is so
disgusting but i i i was so into her and
i wanted to make sure she didn't think i
was a [ __ ] so i did it and she was sick
[ __ ] horrible a few things about that
uh indians and havoc right so that's the
lie and then also um they would take the
blood and put it on their face they
wouldn't drink it i think your friend
lied to you i think you're right to you
i believe that's true
[ __ ] indians not something i
associate with each other and vodka
doesn't go well with native american
people because it's called fire water
and it did a lot of damage because they
don't apparently have the enzyme or
something happening it makes them more
aggressive look that up chin uh native
americans don't a lot of times depending
on their you know but for the most part
it was
did not have the same effect so
on this guy eric herbermann he was on
rogan he was talking about how some
small parts german yeah yeah there's a
small part of the population it's
usually northern europeans that have a
gene that when they drink alcohol
they get an absolutely euphoric feeling
same toxic effects but they get so
euphoric they can keep drinking go to
sleep wake up and keep drinking again
they feel amazing they don't get alcohol
poisoning like you and i were that's
pretty cool yeah uh no we don't want
would you google chin i just native
american style no no no no no no they
have such a deep history with alcoholism
and no it's like you know how like uh
certain asians can't have dairy like
they just don't respond right to it yeah
that's how
uh
i think they get addicted faster than
say a european does there's something
about
the their their genetic makeup that
cause them to be more susceptible to
alcoholism
they can drink and they immediately get
addicted to it or something [ __ ] up so
anyway that's what i've heard i may
may be wrong this is the same guy that
told you they drink vodka oh no
no
alcohol yeah
why do you think native americans are
suspected of alcohol they're you know
i don't know i don't know historical
trauma they're saying i don't know
that's just saying them yeah they like
the truth
you know a missing enzyme
inheritor deficiency and one of the m
sides that's for all asians breaking
down alcohol that's what they're the
flesh thing all asians yep the uh
chinese japanese korean and you'd have
to assume something that gets passed on
to native americans um well because no
because native americans were hailed
originally from asia yeah yeah they came
over the bering strait or they may have
sailed there see people always think
that the europeans like christopher
columbus were the first people the
spanish were the first people to hit the
the new world not so it it could very
well have been chinese people
about that yeah in fact they found
chinese anchors
off the various coasts that are way
older hold on dude are you saying the
chinese america i'm saying there's
there's a lot of evidence that the
chinese very well could have been the
first don't let them hear that i know
the first settlers of america which then
became native americans
how about that
like even aztecs
no i think aztecs were were a very
different thing they they were
indigenous to that region yeah right
yeah although
it is interesting how
although the idea was that civilization
came from africa like the first the
first
yeah well sort of well however humans
evolved from apes the first humans
started in africa and then migrated
their way out yeah
we don't know because because
how do they do that though because
weren't the tectonic plates before they
shifted the world was all just one big
landmass continent right that's what
they say they call it pangaea but this
is all this might be bro science in
general even though those are theories
we don't know oh trust me i don't think
anyone's right like
can i give you a link there's also it's
also possible that people
back then had developed crazy amounts of
technology we just forgot about it or
that this whole thing's a simulation
i hate when people think of simulation i
know but the elon musk
one billion chance that it's not a
simulation like mathematicians he's a
billionaire so he's like yeah this this
world's so great he's running simulation
yeah that's the guy working at dairy
queen for a simulation yeah dude i make
[ __ ] blizzards every day this isn't a
simulation
well i'm just trying to strip enough
money out of my check to afford some
math are we in a game though
are you are you do you have an avatar i
don't think so i don't know
that [ __ ] no no it only comes from
really successful people nobody broke
has ever said that no but but
mathematicians and scientists scientists
seem to think that
that is mathematically the only
explanation but like in other words that
might be the new evolution so evolution
is true but it's true within a larger
context called simulation but also think
about a math uh someone who's into
numbers in science isn't going to
believe in higher being right like so
for them that's that's how they can make
sense of all this right hold on you're
right but you might be talking about
adam and eve
i mean i don't know i don't i don't know
you know yeah
hold on you closet christian
i
that's what they need to do though you
know to make sense of the world just
it's like elon i mean come on yeah
you're building it
yeah a jillian time's over
you know
hey b saturday is a big day for the ufc
and next week is a big day for me
because i am visiting baltimore for the
first time august
yes sir august 4th through the 6th i'm
in baltimore your boy's never been i'm
gonna ray lewis my wiener all over that
town that means i'm doing a cool dance
that's baltimore and then chicago one
night only at the den theater friday
august 26th den theater chicago get you
some because the next day is the tough
mudder you can sign up right now thick
or tough mudder where the 10 a.m heat on
the 27th that's the thick mudder promo
code is team brendan to save 10 percent
off all the race all the race you know
what man think boy.com where you be
you're going to a good spot i'm going to
austin texas cap cities the new cap
cities july 28th 29th that's thursday
friday saturday this coming thursday
friday saturday i got nashville
tennessee at zany's august 26th and 27th
that's a saturday great run buddy friday
saturday i can't wait then i got spokane
washington's comedy club september 22
24. now um you want to stay in coeur
d'alene i'm going to stay there about 30
minutes outside gorgeous yeah good call
i love mma dude do you like money too i
love money in mma i wonder if you could
help me i got something for you this
saturday is ufc 277 right and you can
make some big bucks with my friends at
draftkings because you're gonna be
watching with your boys yeah now put
some money with draftking sports but
they're the official sports betting
partner of the ufc and this saturday new
customers can bet five dollars on any
fight to win 100
in free bets win or lose you want even
more action brian oh my god dude you can
also double your winnings on a same
fight parlay combined multiple bets like
which fighters will win how long the
fight will last uh submission knockout
decision uh will it go all the rounds
all that stuff just place your ufc 277
same fight and if it hits you'll win
double draftkings is a safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdraw your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code fighter bet five
dollars on any ufc 277 fighter to win
get hundred dollars in free bets no
matter what that's code fighter this
saturday at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
see show notes for
details i want my greens i want my
probiotics i want my prebiotics i want
my fiber i want 75 vitamins minerals i
want them whole food sourced ingredients
i want a multivitamin i want a
multi-mineral i want a probiotic i want
a greens superfood food blend because a
lot of times i don't have time to get
all the nutrition i need through fruits
and vegetables
do you know of anything i can do i
really just show you the wrapper dude
yeah from the jump i went oh he needs a
g1 what absolutely he's one yes eight
ounces of water join the movement be
athletes all right moms podcasters comic
stepmom step ants grandma grandpa
it's delicious i don't want any gmos i
don't want nasty chemicals i don't want
artificial stuff okay all right and i
don't want more than one gram of sugar
now can you help me with that yeah ag-1
there it is athletic green keto what if
i'm paleo what about it doesn't matter
we got you dude athletic greens is going
to give you immune supporting free one
year supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase if
you visit athletic greens.com fighter
today again all you got to do is go to
athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give a g one a try all right i'll do
it
how different is his life when he wakes
up in the morning what do you think
pretty different he's right behind
twitter rogan and imagine waking up and
we tweet yeah now matching waking up
like i like this i'm gonna buy it you
call your assistant hey how much is
twitter shake i don't what
like you wanna buy like somebody no i
wanna buy
all of it yeah let us call up 44 billion
i'll take it i'll take it i'll take it
no weird no he's backing out yeah
that makes sense though i i know a lot
of people have said he's not going to
buy
made no sense or he wanted to but they
wouldn't release certain things i was
more uh but his life's pretty crazy
i don't know so rogan and jordan
peterson are saying that their
experience with those guys that they
work 24 7. like they work
they never are not working literally
they're working all the time all the
time all the time yeah you guys that are
really good at capitalism yeah that's
why they're brilliant but who's jordan
peterson wrote hold on
elon musk she's nice stone cold fox they
were friends though supported affair i
said they're still friends this is all
beyonce she's gorgeous
man her husband is gorgeous too who is
that guy he's a co-founder of google
you know you know he's rich dude i mean
name a nap
you know what i'm saying
well yeah looking like that you're not
gonna get that girl right right
look at those two
sergey brin looks like a
bond villain though he really does
he really does allegedly banged google
co-founder sergey god damn banged i know
adjective we're going to bang well
that's whole mars catalog elon bang
google co-founder sergey brin's wife
leading them to get a divorce and
apparently they're no longer oh this is
total bs sergey and i are friends and we
were at a party together last night i've
only seen a goal twice in three years
both times with many other people around
nothing romance now remember a lot of
this is coming out from the left trying
to sabotage
all this [ __ ]
that one goes on
and yeah and remember yeah look yolan
put political attacks on it will
escalate dramatically in the coming
months because he's trying to buy
twitter and you know go against all that
freedom of speech
he's for freedom of speech he's even
donald trump right so he says that he
goes yeah the character assassination
attacks have reached a new level this
year but articles are all he should
[ __ ] sue the people we're crazy hours
so there's just as much time for
shenanigans none of the key people move
on these electronic dooms were even he
has the money to go after people he has
the money to sue these no you don't have
though the time you don't have time no
no that's what you're saying you get a
team of people i work so much i don't
know what to do get a team alert just
drag them through court [ __ ] with them
they're the worst people in the world
people like this you just but when you
talk about like elon like how different
his life being that
to gillian or whatever but think about
it jordan pierce and rogan are like you
know he just works all the time yeah so
does jordan peterson wrote it yeah yeah
no it's it's all millionaires talking
about other
uh buildings yeah yeah you know so yeah
it must be a tough life man it works all
that's been and then both of them work
all the time but let's be honest like to
get successful at anything you're you're
always working
oh yeah i mean
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
there's nothing about it i never stopped
trying to do something and build
something up you know i'm reassessing
and i realize you're doing it wrong i
gotta do something different [ __ ] you
know
it is what it is um
is it true that they banned our boy joe
rogan
shadow man shadow band i don't know i
don't know i saw something on his own
look at his instagram but he's so famous
does it matter if you're real
something's up with it i mean your post
won't get as many views
uh
this is kind of [ __ ] i'm hoping this
is just a glitch people are saying they
can't follow me is anyone else having
this issue oh
that well that's beyond shadow man
then they shut my [ __ ] down yesterday
getting spooky out there i just shot by
me right after i did your show heading
to covid no rhyme or reason my friend
welcome to the club fellas and i even
spoke to instagram but they won't admit
to shadow banning schultz said man they
shut my [ __ ] down yesterday getting
spooky out here but they but so when you
talk to them like i learned talk
uh instagram i you saw friends there so
i talked about i hate it well clearly
shout out any i don't know mark and the
guys told me they came in we got shadow
ben
so i
talked to the guy and they won't ever uh
admit to shadow band but they'll say oh
there's some uh interesting kind of
things going on with your profile let us
look into it you know blah blah and they
go through the thing and then two days
later like hey i think it's all good
and then like a week goes by
but it's more than just the search right
because that's one thing people point to
i couldn't find you what we've noticed
is
it extremely limits your non-follower
reach so it your post might reach your
followers maybe it's dampened a little
bit but when you look at the analytics
of like my post reached this many people
fifty percent used to be the
non-follower reach of your post or
whatever now it's like and that's how
you grow right we need a whistleblower
but rogan's what we have but bro rogan's
is another level you can't even click
follow that's not shadow band that's
i mean yeah you wouldn't say it's being
blocked but it's definitely pretty
outrageous yeah that's the worst i've
ever seen and now we're all gonna get
blocked on here because we're talking
about it
it's weird right
you can't well you still can't shut your
mouth you got to keep talking because
that can't happen well you can't shut
this down i mean youtube can read i see
as well yeah yeah isn't it how they just
censor everything
are they you know that's the question
half-heartedly because they're just
going we're not going to reach anybody
new or we're going to limit you
i think they're not going to silence you
but they can make it very difficult
they make it so you're not in like the
algorithm which is what you need to grow
and get vietnamese and there are people
in positions of tech power that have a a
big incentive to keep a guy like joe
rogan quiet that's for sure oh yeah so
it's not shouldn't the ship rolls
downhill yeah so anybody associated with
it yeah it's just so
it's just such a [ __ ] i mean you're
gonna silence these people so they can't
get bigger because you don't agree with
one of their
you know something they said well
peterson's banned from twitter
well you took himself off of it right no
no he's banned was he banned now yeah
because of the the the force right thing
no because of uh he said uh he talked
about elliot page
and basically said
um
he called her
physician a criminal which is a surgeon
a criminal it's a little extreme yeah it
is but um he's going to stream huh
i'm a jordan peterson famous oh my god
dan i i think that sometimes you can
overreach
twitter reportedly removes the tweets
yeah he said if you wanna get the
criminal physician yeah remember when
pride was a sin
and uh ellen page just had her breasts
removed by a criminal physician
because he thought that her he said how
many young girls are going to emulate
that who are already confused because as
a physician i mean as a clinician i
guess he was talking about the mass
psychosis or the mass sort of social
contagion that can lead people to do a
lot of crazy things
so they may not be trans but they can
because of social contagions and young
women especially young girls can tend to
be
way more susceptible to that kind of
stuff okay but if you're elliot page and
you feel this way which clearly i would
not have i wouldn't know if you're out
and clearly you feel this way and you're
gonna go to the extremes we remove your
breasts and she's happier
okay yeah well she's not supposed to do
it because she's worried about
influencing young girls right you know
it's like she just live her truth
you know and she's also older he's older
so he's older i agree so you know he's
at an age where he can make that
decision i agree with you i wouldn't
have done that i wouldn't i would i also
tweeted sorry not beautiful i i just
some of these things are not necessary
it's not the fight to pick i don't hear
my i don't even care like whatever
jordan peterson and jordan peterson i i
like jordan peters and the majority of
stuff he says i agree with but then
my thing is if you're gonna go that hard
in the paint on uh twitter my biggest
issue he's like i'm gonna get out now
i'm not gonna play anymore it's like no
no no dude you just dipped your toe in
the pool you hit the beehive sit in it
dude take the abuse because you know
what you're doing and so you're gonna do
that and then just dip out no no no no
they uh apparently gave him an option to
delete the tweet they're like you can
delete this tweet and like get your
account back and he's like i'd rather
die than you know
freedom of speech for him yeah i think
it might be an overreach because i think
he's super effective being the guy who
puts all the [ __ ] in perspective i don't
think he needs to go so hard in the
paint
like in in it's the shock factor stuff
well but do you think he's really doing
that or is this
yeah do you really mean this stuff i
think what he's really good at is
debating people intellectually right who
are on the other side of the of the
equation and then you learn a lot from
both sides sometimes yes but but i think
when you go
ham on just
like an issue like elliot page or a girl
who's a little overweight on sports
illustrated
now we're getting into this how you
personally emotionally feel and and i
don't think how he personally and
emotionally feels is as powerful as his
intellect that hurts his brain i think
it hurts his overall
value of what he brings says now this is
the narrative yes it's kind of like with
rogan when the with the vaccines and all
that stuff
like
them painting him in that light
you know
he's so much more than that and then the
audience was like even if they didn't
know who rogan was there
who was this guy that became familiar
with and they look into it like oh
that's actually pretty cool so he got
bigger you know what i'm saying but
rogan's not dying on that i tried i've
never really said much about vaccines
especially with the cover vaccine
because i don't know anything i just
don't know anything i don't i'm not a
scientist i don't know the f that when i
open my mouth about [ __ ] like that no
matter what side of the equation i am i
always regret it because i end up being
i'm just an idiot about stuff like that
it's you got to be careful also if
you're listening to me on anything
health related you already have bigger
problems
yeah if if if you go home and your mom's
like wait hold on why aren't you wearing
a mask you're like brendan's shop you're
already losing my bag
you know but you can always ask
questions i just find that's just as
revealing if you have an opinion on
something ask somebody who claims to
know
right a lot of times people don't know
and see and just see what kind of where
your question gets them yeah if you can
make them uncomfortable make them yeah
for the majority i mean i don't hate
anyone
politicians left right i don't hate
anybody i don't care they all have an
agenda i don't hate and they have to do
their job right that's what they signed
up for but it's also
they they also a lot of them didn't know
what the hell was going on so they made
some mistakes but saying we didn't know
what i find ironic i like the ironic
comments and questions what i think is a
true statement i could say is without
getting into who i like or who i don't
because i'm not a fan of trump's never
have been but the only person that can
get joe biden elected again if you don't
like joe biden i think the only person
that could get joe biden elected again
is trump
i think he's so polarizing that if he
ran against biden i think there are
enough people who have seen numbers
lately
and women close b
yeah wouldn't be close trump would
absolutely mop the floor with them you
think so not even close
even democrat i mean it's just you know
it's like
you know mine's holy right by bike dude
yeah leader of the free world
yeah well he's an older man yeah but i
know but they were like we'll take
anything but trump and i like holy [ __ ]
dude he's reading the cue cards like
anchorman yeah he's like an end quote
there
walk to right
you know not heads like yeah it bums me
obviously it blows me out you know where
america he deserves respect regardless
of where what you think he's your
president yeah i don't know i would
never disrespect him
but there is a reality in life cognitive
function and yeah you kind of gotta have
your [ __ ] together too that gig
or not or just you're just a puppet you
know yeah and everyone else runs it
around you
huh but yeah the the latest statistics
i've seen and almost all even the ones
on people who don't like trump mop the
floor with them right
well they get dicey
life is stranger than fiction
right mark well i was going to say the
reason you know
the political landscape of 2020 was
trump messed up covet or that was at
least in there the things were something
was going wrong and we needed to
recorrect
i think there's a lot of people who
voted for biden who'd probably rather
have 2020 back than you know right now
with inflation and kind of the real
stuff that people think about like how
am i going to pay for gas and groceries
trump called a lot of it he was like if
you vote buy it and he to tease like
this is what's going to happen yeah you
know so much of this is like it's funny
how we spend a lot of time on the coasts
right we spend a lot of time la is just
so different than so many places like
milwaukee for example or most of america
are just people living their lives i was
really excited this weekend because ben
askren came to my show i just got he's
so like he was back there i didn't even
know
yeah i just got a dm
like i was going through my dm's i
haven't checked and he just said hey bro
me and my wife loved you you guys you
were really funny i was like dude like
ben asking so anyway the next day i get
my memory he calls me because come over
and watch the fights
and i go over to his house i'm like oh
just ufc london so it's during the day
exactly and i was thinking to myself
like people in l.a we climb this wall
that dude has
these three
beautiful kids
his wife is [ __ ] a complete smoke
show he's a great guy he just coaches
wrestling just loves that and gets you
dressed oh [ __ ] huge pregnant and
then get this what's great about him is
we bonded on the toehold thing because
he that's all he's in he's only we're
still holding that's he's just a total
freak he actually tried to invest in the
company which i didn't know so he's he's
got his flip-flops i got my flip-flops
he goes come out to the back i go okay
he's got all this land you know what he
has in the back backyard of disc golf
course like an entire frisbee golf
[ __ ] course yeah so we're
we're playing frisbee golf disc golf in
the in his back [ __ ] yard with his
three
what i'm saying is that like a guy like
that in a lot of ways has figured it out
he's just a moderate american who
figures this [ __ ] out and i was thinking
to myself all the stuff we talk about
sometimes has no relevance to somebody
in milwaukee somebody in wisconsin
it's almost like they've already figured
out life they've figured it out they
don't need you and they don't need they
don't need politicians telling them how
to live their lives that's how most
americans are i think yes they just
reminded me of that he's a great uh
representative of like look at him by
the way olympian look at his body
average dude olympian
yes well the comment he's even terrible
at that um do you realize he was on the
national team the olympic team wrestling
do you realize he was a world champion
in one championship
you realize he's a world champion
bellator yeah you realize he finally ufc
you don't even care about that like
excuse me sir what do you do yeah
what have you ever excelled at yeah it's
weird right why would somebody say that
yeah
yeah i don't know what you're doing
that's why i read that comment oh god
are you [ __ ] dumb
i imagine it's like we're doing i'm
living my mom's basement like oh my god
if there are people that can help you
if you hate on bad ass when you got some
big problems you got some big problems
a good amount of it you've been asking
that ice cream has a good amount of it
yeah hold on it's uh 2 000 unbelievable
[ __ ] 17 calling really
what
why because he keeps winning well he
would talk a lot of [ __ ] though yeah
yeah and back it up
yeah well you i mean back in the day
yeah but then yeah he got to the ufc at
the end of his career you know he was a
tough go for him that's fine yeah and
then
that was a tough go and then you know
you got knocked out by jake paul i
interviewed him you know for about the
jake paul thing and i don't know if
people don't realize this but he's not
got to make excuses and he didn't work
on his boxing i actually talked to him
like i could tell i was like watching
you hit me i go you didn't he goes
because i had just had hip surgery three
months before and i wasn't supposed to
do anything
he called john wayne parr and he was
like hey you're kicking it back after
four months he goes yeah yeah yeah
because my surgeon told me i can't do
anything for a year he goes that's
[ __ ] so he calls his surgeon and
he's like what the [ __ ] assistant goes
look man i have a lower
fail ready because what's your favorite
is one in one in a thousand he goes i'll
take my [ __ ] chances but really ben
rode a bike for about a week
and then did some mit hitting with
freddie roach for one week and then some
other guy for two weeks in a week yeah
and he didn't know he he just didn't
know that jake paul was training as hard
as he was he didn't know he was like
let's make a lot of money on going he
knew because he he told me he's like if
if jake paul is as good as we think he's
like yeah we're knocked out yeah yeah
you talked to him before yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but how about that
that stuff's out there but he he was
just he barely tried yeah he was a money
player right
right and he paid fairly fast and now
now he's just now he's just happy great
sense of humor about himself though yes
like i said to michael what do you want
to do coach wrestling i love coaching i
was like yeah he's such a good person
such a good coach and also you know hall
of famer not in the ufc but mma hall of
fame well i didn't know also about that
in the wrestling world he was one of the
most innovative wrestlers oh yeah he was
an incredible style came out yeah came
up yeah monster came with a super
monster do you ever watch matches of
this now i have yeah i never did before
pretty cool huh yeah yeah he's a freak
just refusing taking down me and rogan
for [ __ ] i don't know eight years
someone asked him for him to get in the
ufc i remember that was too late but
well i said that in the interview i said
the reason you got in the ufc i think
was because rogan
you know was talking about all you just
said you both were you both weren't mean
to me
i didn't know because and you also got
that story from me and didn't credit me
so i heard rogan talking about it yeah
from me no no but it's numberless clip
of it yeah [ __ ] you oh yeah yeah i've
won been in ufc forever but time you got
in you know it's like yeah you know 34
year old running back yeah that hip yeah
and then i put him to the [ __ ]
through the mill you know so you were
the one who was bringing this i've
wanted him in there forever yeah me and
rogan both were we we've yeah we've been
saying oh we'd love to see ben asking
ufc ben asking ufc and then finally they
made the deal happen
trade for mighty mouse you know what he
told me too he goes i just never took a
day off i never took a day off and i and
i never took one day not even a day off
in high school look at his hair
look at that hair
that's part of what it where his
strength comes from his samson like look
uh tyrone woodley was on that team too
in college
oh that's right i mean woodley they
train a lot yeah they train a lot yeah
and they're both at rufus
he said he said that i love to innovate
because i used to think about like i
just love the idea of
figuring out the best way to beat the
person in front of me and you do that by
just coming up with things that they
haven't thought of or seen before yeah
yeah he was so good that's really cool
yeah and just refusing to get taken to
like he would just bend and contort and
he's like he gotta take down somebody
had his legs up in the air and he's like
down he's upside down grabbing their
ankles and he ends up getting the
takedown
[ __ ] man just but it's also like that
mindset of
you know when i first started learning
wrestling you kind of almost you like
don't realize there's so many ways to
not concede a takedown you're just like
oh he's leveraged me i have to give it
up and then work on getting that's
because that's how you learn yeah you
come up with but then when it's like
what if you're gun to head
you know
like if you get taken down right now he
gets two you're gonna die yeah come up
with some interesting [ __ ]
imagine that's your kid's wrestling
coach like his wrestling camp's huge
huge he's got five schools yeah yeah
ama he's a great guy great guy he's a
big crypto guy yeah he is yeah and i was
arguing
because he goes i'll change her mind i'm
like i'm not doing [ __ ] crypto
he's got books on it he's got a whole
library he loves crazy like an expert on
crypto and then when i was a show he's
like you haven't paid encrypt only no
why do i do that so i'm telling you
that's the move mango
or they could just pay me an american
cash and i can just buy american dollars
i'll take america yeah i could just yeah
i could just and then buy my own crypto
i don't need them to figure it out yeah
but i'm pretty sure he got paid in
crypto from one of us some of his sites
it's hilarious he's an interesting dude
yeah man yeah that's worth half now ben
that's right half that's right it'll
bounce back
his kids it's just that genetic thing
his kids are as rough and tumble as he
is like he is a jungle gym in his house
he is a jungle gym he sits and they
climb on him
24 7. the four-year-old
runs straight at you he will run
straight at you and not stop and just
hit you with his head you're like oh
he's a boy yeah yeah but the girls are
the same way yep
pull-ups doing all kinds of things great
dude i love ben that's cool you met up
with yeah man i i really enjoyed it yeah
i'd assume that you had talked about it
before i'm like oh he's doing the best
of with uh with ben affleck yeah but he
yeah i did but he's he he's also like
kind of what i liked about it is that
sometimes you see people's lives and
where they're living and stuff and
you're like that is as bucolic that is
as
picture perfect as it gets yeah where
was that brian and and he's right
outside my walk move there
no you're just saying like how great and
like how
like how beautiful it is and that's
america move there
put your money where your mouth is move
there move to the middle of take it easy
hold on
just i don't don't put that much
pressure on me i was just i'm just
saying you're saying that they got it
figured out man we're in this rat race
move
to the outskirts of
let me know milwaukee you do don't force
my hand i'm not saying i'll get crazy i
don't know it's cheaper out there right
that's like my buddy my buddy larry
mcconnell got so done with my one friend
just to always say i'm gonna go guy i'd
like to kick that guy's ass and finally
larry goes like this go ahead go ahead
and the guy goes yeah [ __ ] i i should
he goes god then god
he's there
yeah no i should and he goes no i'm
saying don't should go ahead you always
say that go do it because hey he wants
to find you
my buddy turned out to be a chicken [ __ ]
and he wasn't going to do that yeah yeah
let's take a break dude i i just i'm
feeling stressful i got anxiety i got
i'm having trouble sleeping
i just i just need something to help me
out and i want it to be natural don't
give me a heavy narcotic dude bro i'm
not gonna give you heavy narcotic but do
you know what it is man what you need
cbd now daddy uses it every single day
at night to fall asleep right yeah and
my friends at next evo naturals they
have their sleep cbd i take three of
those and we getting
sleep yeah i swear by it now a lot of
y'all like i tried cbd it's not great
dude you haven't tried next evo naturals
it works faster is stuff that we're like
literally four times better than regular
cbd oil yes sir that's them that is them
dude so you're getting a lot of cbd and
you're getting exactly what you order
this it takes the guesswork out for you
all right works faster too right way
faster that's why i use it but right 30
minutes before bed your boy's sleeping
like a freaking baby you have told me
this oh i swear by it and i didn't bring
it to uh san diego and i slept awful and
that's why i look like this right now so
shut up this is something you actually
found on your own i love these guys yes
stop wondering if cbd is right for you
tried next evo naturals all right the
capsules that's what i use they have
gummies mints topical creams clinically
proven to be better absorbed by your
body get 25 off your first order of 40
or more at nextevo.com with promo code
fighter that's 25 off at next evo
n-e-x-t-e-v-o dot com promo code fighter
oh yeah you laugh so hard jay threw up
in the green room in san diego you know
dude he threw up so loud
the weekend's over it's saturday night
they're trying to get people out there's
something like
someone like uh he threw up someone
flooded the bathroom in the men's room
so they're like hey they told me like
you know i take
my time with the meet and greets and
then they get it listen there's a flood
in the bathroom there's [ __ ] everywhere
can you just hurry this up and i was
like well they paid me so i'm gonna do
my thing so when it's done then you get
because if they don't have to go the
bathroom gives a [ __ ] it's back there
like all right we'll just try and make
it quicker so i do whatever my time then
we're all in the green room and we're
sitting there and they're like everybody
out like mad out everybody get out but
have the bathroom everybody get up and
we're all talking i didn't you know
realize jay left and share
and you hear is somebody throwing up in
the goddamn path
because he said he smelled the [ __ ] or
something i don't know what's going on
jake comes back his eyes are all classy
i go hey that was you
he was yeah i don't feel good like what
the [ __ ] dude what are you doing
he's just so funny
he's so funny throughout the loudest
i've ever heard probably quietly it's
not close to the green room yeah so loud
how are you guys live when you puke some
people say they puke quietly no i don't
i i puke loud yeah girls with eating
disorders quietly correct yeah this is
correct guys i don't know how you can
i can't control it
it's all
and like you is there anything worse
it's the best ab workout of all time
like my core is so sore is there
anything worse i remember i was going it
feels good too though jimmy burke was
with me and all i was doing was going i
was taking topanga canyon down
from ventura down to the pch so you know
it's a little windy oh it's the windy so
i was doing
i didn't think i went on old tapanga
road so it's even more windy you're
driving you're passing i'm driving uh
now jimmy doesn't drive you see he lives
in new york city so he's never in a car
i had to pull over on the side of the
road and he was on his hands and knees
yeah i get it for if i could drive there
for a half hour
yeah yeah
i get motion sickness
that's crazy
that's exactly where it's out to you
naked and freight contestant melanie
rauscher found dead
uh
jason momoa got a crash motorcycle yeah
until canyon he's always that's god i've
seen him probably i don't know five six
times every time it's done to pay canyon
every single time i see him yeah he
lives up there
must have so he got a head-on crash with
a car i think a motorcycle he was he was
in a car and then hit a motorcycle but
no one really was really at fault oh he
was in a car in a motorcycle yeah see
that's misleading because his you know
motorcycle accident he's always on a
motorcycle always always always he's
always at uh paying a cafe there with
his family oh he's always wow and he's
on a motorcycle they must take your car
soon see i'll meet you there
he's aqua man dude yeah man but he's
fine yeah they're the guys should be
fine too
all right so nothing happens yeah keep
going who's down there who are the is
that's his stun double
maybe the director of that movie
hey that might be a stunt devil
handsome basket yeah no [ __ ] they both
are yeah
look at that shepherd no look at that
old man looks [ __ ] sweet this is
awesome
he's he couldn't look better he couldn't
look cooler
yeah he ran over i want to look like
that guy in the back seat too
why is he in the back though i think he
might be a jerk let's see
it's my best friend
mano my best we did her mom
i mean aren't our way to the dream team
oh so with his best friend probably
being a movie in this and promoting it
yeah
okay he made it he made a movie okay
that's cool called the sweet girl
what else you got jen
uh alligator attack hell yeah
always we don't have videos of this
stuff
but um so seven year old woman oh yeah
just by a golf course she fell into a
pond she tried to like
stay afloat and she was like
70.
so two alligators came took her under
game they think two alligators they
think though they they thought before
but then they concluded it she had like
uh something with their like a fractured
neck and something else too yeah yeah so
they had to get the both uh but it was
like an eight foot or a little
well hold on they didn't eat her it
might be that she
drowned and then they got her
they were saying that the alligators
were next to her when she was in the
water and then she just went under they
said they saw an alligator in the area a
lot of it's fishy i got a skeptical hip
so there's a guy that actually answered
or called 9-1-1 so he confirmed as cause
of the woman's shot
but the guy though
yeah man of course no they will kill you
hold on the man so hold up uh the man
was out of breath lying on the ground as
he tried to stay on the phone with 9-1-1
he thought he was going to pass out i
don't think i'm going to make it help
help
that's the guy that was trying to save
her okay uh while on the phone with 911
library the other bystander said that he
could see a gator right in front of me
during the call okay
so there were two gators one that was
right next to wing's head and the other
that was by her body keeping her
floating up
two alligators one eight feet ten inches
the other seven sevens
removed from the pond why would you
remove them
that's where they lived they sometimes
they don't they lose their fear of
humans and then it becomes very
dangerous so if you feed alligators the
problem is that then they you don't have
food and you become the food and that's
why kids and dogs you have to keep them
away from the water's edge don't let
your kid go in florida to the waters out
no we have a royal you can't go to a
pool in florida no we have no idea
what's in there you don't know there's
too many dangerous things yep so they
they think she
brian's saying she drowned and then
they're saying no they confirmed that i
was alligator yeah two giant alleys
being by her body and she's floating
around you think they're like
let's see what she does hey old guy old
guy walking his dog
walking his dog on a path taken by an
alligator and dragged right in killed
exactly that's my point yep she died by
alligator a woman a woman goes for a jog
it's nighttime she dangles her feet
over the bridge
mr alligator grabs her they found her
just her torso because did the old death
roll on the arms and the legs oh there
it is investigators said two alligators
spotted the woman and grabbed her while
she was in the water
yeah yeah
well
i'd rather attack i'd rather get
attacked by a [ __ ] shark i'll tell
you what shark week step their game up
but make fun of how they always run the
same [ __ ] bits over and over they had
one last night this dude he's as known
as like one of the shark experts they
say is away with great whites they show
him like
he kind of did if that's me too i wrote
i'm like oh god dude they show this dude
like pat in a great way you know pen the
great white dude he goes into this uh
like kind of this contraption but it's
made it's plastic
he's in a in a plastic square so think
of a square that see-through plastic
that they put together like a lego he's
on top so he can like move and jump out
if he wants and he's just sitting there
while a great white's just roaming
around big great huge great white with a
great white you can and they're like we
should have noticed this and they didn't
know this was going to happen and this
one i was like all right shark week you
got me finally so the big great white
comes by the guys knocking on the thing
i guess he was not gonna think like keep
him away but the great white bumps it or
he just bumps it to see what it is
circles around goes into the dark
comes back this time bumps a little
harder but not like horrible just kind
of like oh he's just curious and the
guy's like you know he's trying to be
the expert he's like this is what these
great whites do he's just checking out
some new in his territory okay cool
great white goes away into the abyss
then you see him come and you're like
and they don't they're filming he's like
talking dude
boom
blast through the [ __ ] plastic what
breaks this
[ __ ] plexi glass and goes tries
biting the guy
like like came out of the water the guy
flies out he bit he missed it because
the alligator from the most tracked and
like the plastic hit and the guy went
this way and the great white went off to
into the abyss but with plastic all in
his mouth
oh that's not good here's the problem so
that show started at seven my daddy was
in town my daddy goes because i was like
alright got it let's move on my dad goes
no let's leave it i went all right
you're the boss you're my dad i'm gonna
leave it oh dad
this happened they've already showed it
all they can do is talk about this for
the next
two hours it's from seven to nine we've
seen the there's nothing else dad that's
right we've seen it this is it
yeah but we can't obviously we can't
show any of this starting but can i see
just this should i just see it so i know
what we're talking about
first of all he's dressed like a seal
right uh yeah
look at that oh oh why would you go look
at that great white
oh that's very interesting yeah you're
asking for it pal first of all it has
700 views what the hell is going on
you're really going to victim blame
believe this i am going to pick
something right now because you're
playing with fifa fire look at the size
of that [ __ ] shark
i'm trying to think
for those of you that can't see he's in
a
clear con contraption yeah but it's like
a sheet plastic
like
i could swim and probably knock it out
damn little in a [ __ ] great white
shark
that's right great white's like oh this
isn't interesting so look he's bumping
it he's all right i'm just checking out
man he's bumping but he wants to eat
that [ __ ] thing no he's like the
expert was like he's just he's curious
uh-huh he's curious so then the great
white's like all right here we go i'm
gonna bump it again
right yeah little bumper cars he's doing
some bumping little bumps he's bumping
up now this is him and he thinks he's
mad he thinks he's best friends with
great right now the great white goes
okay i've bumped a few times yeah let's
see what's in there daddy
oh jesus
oh my god
oh my god
holy [ __ ] dude
best part
ever on discovery week oh my god that's
scary
get on that [ __ ] thing and get out
now look at the shark glass in the mouth
or plastic are you out of your [ __ ]
mind now look at the shark guy hey
dum-dum so so he's trying to stay afloat
on that like that's gonna help [ __ ] this
dude because i put my head under water
so i could see where the shark was at oh
that's so [ __ ] scary
i told my dad you know how little shark
god that's a knife
did you see that that thing would have
killed him
let me see that [ __ ] let me see that
[ __ ] again
that's [ __ ] nuts it's hilarious and
the shark's not even going down are you
joking
dude he's so lucky he didn't get killed
i need you to calm down though a little
bit oh it's not that crazy that thing
went to bite him
yes and no that's what the experts were
debating oh no he wasn't he didn't do
the full on like the full on no no
oh that was a
it's like super mario with the coin yeah
i mean it's nothing no no he bumped him
and that was a curiosity bite yep it was
also plastic yeah but he just went went
right through that plastic by the way i
would go through that plastic but you're
saying i mean if you want a full-on boom
have you seen some of these videos of
the breaching oh they get 10 feet in the
air yeah but that's because it's a seal
and they know what it is yeah
it wasn't sure what that [ __ ] guy was
but that thing that wasn't full-on mouth
first but not full what if it was with
you just come in the ass first
sometimes no they always he's always
there
he had his mouth open no i don't like
mark you know i don't like what mark
said he goes have you ever seen the
great white breach the water and get a
seal yeah dude i'm 39. yeah we seen him
i've seen every shark week since i've
been alive that was morning
all day i didn't assume i'd be the first
person to play the gym but it was like a
shark
do they have wings
yeah but you know what shark weed is
trying to get views whatever
they've ran its course i can only see a
great white drum by the [ __ ] water so
many times or a tiger shark whatever eat
a [ __ ] tractor so now they do the
celebrity stuff and then last night's i
was the debut night but it was uh the
jackass crew
and so they showed how sharks will just
kill birds have you ever seen what they
do to birds tiger sharks
tiger sharks yeah tigers bulls dude the
birds yeah it's also bird what the [ __ ]
are you doing with the cats
go to a pond daddy they're in the middle
ocean just like you know what i'm gonna
rest i'm going to rest my wings here if
you don't mind and they're there and
then the shark goes
oh oh chicken dinner daddy
and then chicken overseas bro
yeah seagull of the sea uh-huh seagull c
they're just chilling it yeah and then a
tiger shark which isn't small goes
no oh
yeah i'm gonna kill you yeah and just
[ __ ] chomp well they they here's the
thing i can't believe they can show the
footage they just learn how to swim they
just learn how to swim they're like oh
i'm learning i mean fly i'm learning how
to fly but i'm going to take a rest here
right there they're babies they take
walks
right here they go i'm just going to fly
i can't get up in the air yet hey hey
mama bird could you patrol the waters
and let us know there's a giant [ __ ]
tiger shark hey cow
look so they're chilling right and i
hate birds i can't stand birds yeah
they're [ __ ] stupid what's your issue
with that i need to learn
i can't get enough of that i know boom i
hate birds dude we'll see you later boom
you see see that's a full blown on ray
lewis blitz yes it is he half-assed that
with again the plastic container yeah
you know you know he he's basically in a
see-through trash can and thought it was
going to protect them from a
3 000 pound great white they did that
you know the crocodile hunter steve
irwin did that with a with a
nile crocodile mm-hmm and
mr crocodile came right up and it was so
[ __ ] big you can see it i mean he's
in that plastic thing
it's insane not for me no sir no no sir
you don't want to do that not for me he
was always [ __ ] with these things
dude
and it never caught up with them it
never did a sting they never caught up
with them
[ __ ] with all those wild animals that
never caught out i ever caught up with
him until it dude you know what uh i
cried when he died i cried hard you know
i was like i made it hard i made a joke
about it when i was doing stand up right
after it happened
how dare you total silence yeah oh no no
i made a joke about in san diego and
that dude you don't have my o.j talk
about some
crazy [ __ ] yeah oj whatev all this [ __ ]
michael jackson pedophiles dude i
mentioned steve i had a reference with
steve irwin and stingray
oh oh boo
i went that's too much
but oj the og seems to kill people
you're cool with
people and and honestly i get it let me
know i'm a steve irwin does he get does
he get online hate if he's in this world
yeah oh yeah no he's still not alive
nobody gets nobody gets out on skates
steve burr on the back oh yeah that's
right oh i'd like to see you do that
with a [ __ ] fresh water crocodile or
you know whatever animal activists or
like you shouldn't not even have
activists just the trolls you know
i'd love to see you do that with a
[ __ ] hippo you know or whatever
stupid reference you know
but see very now he'd be older right you
know his family runs his uh yeah
his daughter like got married her
boyfriend like [ __ ] with the koalas
his little boy is identical to him
really same
movements mechanics speak exactly like
he's him reincarnated he's he's a grown
man now right steve
uh his son no his son's not that old his
son would be what 1918 yeah but he is
very similar
what a character he was the mom had to
carry the the
alligator
skin once he passed away and then she
because remember she was kind of like
the side lady right like he never let
her get too involved yeah you like she
was the american who dated or got
married the
alligator expert
right and you just bring her in the boat
while he like jumped in the water
and he would just get reactions from her
remember that like she was just kind of
like the sideshow yes and then he passed
away and she went now's my calling put
on that alligator cape just not the same
i already tell you when i when i was on
mushrooms and i watched him
[ __ ] and and he had his pitbull on
the front
on the [ __ ] front of his boat he's in
africa hell yeah and if and his pit bull
jumps into the water crocodiles
everywhere
there was a wild boar or hedgehog
whatever the [ __ ] it was you know those
warthogs warthog stuck in the mud
his pit bull jumps out grabs on that
warthog now they're in a full-blown
fight he and his the pitbull and warthog
mr irwin jumps off and he's
he's he breaks them up he's called
australian standoff he [ __ ] breaks
the yeah he breaks them up and he's like
i know now and he's trying to give him
that and then you see a crocodile sees
all the commotion
and it's on its way the gang is coming i
i was on mushrooms going
get enough money dude he didn't give a
[ __ ] not a [ __ ] not and how about ain't
that a [ __ ] he was like shooting like
the director's cut of one of his shows
and was like oh check it out fellas it's
a stingray you know they don't like i
have fun dude and the steamy [ __ ]
piercings is hard right this heart that
[ __ ] satan rape dude damn oh and you
know what he made the mistake and it's
just natural it hit him and then he
yanked it out they said if he would have
left it and went to the hospital to be
alive but when he yanked it just ripped
the hole in his heart oh no yeah but he
wouldn't
you know that's what they say though you
keep it in there yeah if you get stabbed
keep the knife in there because the
blood will go around it yeah i don't
know about stabbing don't pull it no so
if you get sick it depends on the knife
if it's just a clean blade hold it there
though
no for real
they say the same thing about that you
get stabbed keep the knife there yeah
but do the criminals go
and then
run off no no they go no and then no but
then when i get stabbed i go i hold it
there i go
i go like this you know you [ __ ] up
right i got your fingerprints on it yeah
wrap his head you put him to sleep like
this one hand because all the criminals
stab and run right so you want to keep
it there stab and release
shout out to steve irwin man one of the
greats
leave it in place as mentioned you will
likely cause more bleeding when you
remove it because it's places
in place it helps hold the vessels cl
cut vessels closed
huh
i'm talking about for the stingray in
general type in would steve irwin be
alive through the left the stingrays
ray in his heart
a [ __ ] out of all the dangerous [ __ ] he
plays with us ain't that a [ __ ]
wow if you get stabbed in the eye you
must cover both eyes
because both eyes move together
there you go
according to a doctor the animal
enthused could have been saved if he had
not hastily pulled the stingray barb
from his chest damn he said the stingray
tray stingray tray that's what he called
a tray effectively acted as a plug in
the moment he removed he bled to death
how big was that like where they see a
bone like a piece of bone into you it's
like it's a bar it's like a barb
really and just hit him right in the in
the heart has to break the chest plate
think that's how hard those [ __ ]
stingers hit
i don't [ __ ] with stingrays dude you
ever seen a steering short tail stingray
6.5 feet
that's a bigger stingray
that killed him
because it went up like this he was over
it and went oh
i'll tell you right now fellas let's say
we're in here and we all did whatever
find the kid wild and we're in uh let's
let's see africa yeah and a stingray got
me
you tell my story like brian right like
you're not gonna be the guy in the water
right if this is the movie 300 you're
the guy with an eye patch right yeah
right you're gonna tell my story so you
have the eye patch you're not a warrior
you have an eye patch you're a good
storyteller yes so you go back to
america and you tell them i got
like there was a i don't know pick an
animal i need an art like a uh a [ __ ]
murderous hippo yeah or there's a lot of
say a lion ate me ass first yeah as i'm
defending the three of you no i just do
this but you gotta make up the story so
my kids because you don't like giving
back
daddy died by this thing right right you
don't want to do that to my kids so you
make up a cool story i just say this
i know
cannibals and he didn't like it asked me
to ask me did he scream
how did he go out did he yell and cry
for that never stopped swinging
and finally when he realized
that was futile he
he kind of smiled a little bit yeah
wrapped his arms around the thing and
then he yelled out i'm going to pleasure
town he said love my kids bruh love my
kids
yeah then he gave me the numbers to his
account
i cleaned him out
i'll tell you what he wanted to what she
did with one eye open yeah like that
from 300.
yeah
i patch i patch mcgee remember that guy
in 300
they're they're
got to be honest you don't like the
movie 300 i'm not saying i didn't like
it i saw it what was what year did it
come out i saw it once in future one of
the greatest movies of all time you've
only seen what my recollection you know
you just look like one of them yeah slow
motion doggy style with lightning
crashing in the background before he
goes to battle i was like that's the
scene no remember just before they go to
the battle the main battle so high when
i saw it oh wow
dude i don't know
it's it's the main battle right there
it's the night before yeah it's like
tonight we dine and where the [ __ ] is
home tonight
i think it was cool story hey guy with
one night come here real quick you know
so we're going to battle tomorrow i need
you to take the horse and run back to
the village tonight he's like no i'm
going to fight you can't fight you have
one eye
you and you can't fight that's why you
have one eye and you're a good
storyteller tell my story yeah
he didn't let him fight
okay i think that guy's in part two now
the main warrior yeah there's no
that's brian
that's me he's just picturing an old guy
this guy's really young and handsome huh
man that's that's a michael fassbender's
first movie where he blew up that's
right
that's right mm-hmm skinny fella have
you guys seen [ __ ] skinny the movie
shame
shane yeah uh-huh uh michael fassbender
nc17 movie races sex addict oh cool it's
such a good movie hey i'm in saw it with
my mom bye you know wasn't the best
choice dick don't they in that oh
yes he's got a piece on him yeah
absolutely mass man's got a real deck
i'm sitting there with my seven-year-old
mom watching this and i i think it's a
masterpiece legitimately but
it was kind of awkward i want to watch
this but uh in this movie shane what
kind of sex addict are we talking here
just like
they show the real addiction
yes
like can't stop looking at porn has sex
with random people all the time like
it'll show how it like interferes with
his life as he's consumed with it yes
um and his good movie oh
incredible like if it wasn't nc 17
it's oscar worthy what year did it come
out
um my guess is gonna be 2012.
i think people would be surprised how
addictive porn can be for some people
right oh yeah
and just everything about a stove
nuanced it's uh what's the director
watch that um yeah that looks that
sounds amazing yeah oh he he directed uh
something else really oh yeah he
directed yes steve mcqueen directed 12
years a slave
so
the filmmaking is phenomenal sounds good
i'll watch that hey was steve mcqueen
the guy who got
who was the guy who where the other guy
came on you owe me my money [ __ ]
yeah i think that's him no uh the
daniels character i think
remember that the director at the awards
show
give him my [ __ ] money
[ __ ] yeah no mo
he was like all right i'll get it to you
i'm on my mind he said to steve perry
lee daniels it was a guy from
rockefeller records oh i'm bringing
dupree
did he ever pay attention oh um
oh i know what you're talking about yeah
yeah with the bald head yeah did he ever
pay him back
damon dash there you go damon dash
hit with five million fraud suit by
damon dash wow
give my money morel is live you all hell
yeah yeah hell yeah get your money
damn five million dollar fraud suit
well you really did a little money huh
what a sketching
let's see here
got a couple here
okay one second so this is another one
it's an animal attack but it's you know
we saw this before we talked about it
before when people catch sailfish
sometimes it jumps into the boat yeah so
this woman got it jumped into the boat
and actually
pierced her crotch area well seven years
old damn it
apparently she's still in the hospital
right now yeah
better than uh hitting you in the
stomach though yeah guess right
is that you think that you'd be on the
lookout for it it's alright guys we're
hunting sailfish right now
you ever seen those things when on the
wire though that's what we call it in
the boat you understand what's on the
wire
those things go ape [ __ ] right and just
yeah they shoot out like [ __ ] rockets
yeah that one's pierced her [ __ ] her
thigh
near a crotch
yeah we should be more specific oh that
would hurt oh my god
man was it in her vagina or not
i don't think they'd want to say that if
it was i know it's it's like they're
being so vague growing up
to encounter
uh-huh what else you got dude there's a
video of her getting stabbed right no
are you sure
yeah she thought i saw it no no we've
seen people get that before though but
not this particular older woman
yeah so
harvey weinstein smelled like poop but
thought it was god's gift a new book
the stench of the weinstein effect is
still lingering monday five years after
mainstream reports of harvey weinstein's
dark sexual reign of terror first came
to light author ken i'll let his
bombshell in the book hollywood ending
harvey weinstein and the culture of
silence dies into the ugly truth of the
disgraced film producer's downfall
um he had some notion that his body was
attractive said he had some notion and
said that his body was attractive um
they smelled a feces had gentle scarred
to the point that he looked like a
vagina vagina
[Music]
uh and back full of oh my god and his
back was full of blackheads
until he really thought he was god's
gifts of don juan
uh he's who spoke to multiple former
miramax films stewie employees weinstein
accusing even the former film producer's
business partner and brother bob i see
him for this but wow
uh actually playing that weinstein you
know had a relationship
it smelled like poop his pipe parts
looked deformed
wow
oh when they showed pictures generals to
the uh jurors they were disgusted
gross uh chin bring up those pictures of
the genitals
why was his wiener all messed up
he had some sort of disease i heard
rogan talking about it before
some sort of weird disease which is
jacked up just on his wiener hitler the
same thing weird not the same thing but
he had a deformed penis allegedly
wounded hitler facebook oh yeah i've
heard that he had the hole on the
underside of his penis
not good
wow
guy's hideous here's another one video
shows taco bell worker hurling boiling
water at customer
new video allegedly shows a dallas texas
taco bell employee hurling boiling water
at a woman and girl who have since filed
a lawsuit uh after asking for their
incorrect order to be remade
the footage released by attorneys for
britain wait so someone ordered like uh
uh [ __ ] uh chalupa yeah they got a
corgita and then she was like hey [ __ ]
i said no cheese yeah she's here oh yeah
wait she hurled it or the customer did
uh the worker hurled it they filled up
[ __ ]
she threw it on who
on the customer
damn that's videos like that or
that's a [ __ ] up thing to do man she
must have just lost her mind
damn that can [ __ ] you up oof
is the video chin here this was better
bam oh my god it's a [ __ ] ton of boiling
water oh my god he's like holy [ __ ] at
least they all have their mask on though
i don't know if that can scare you for
life yeah
oh look how hot is look at all that
steam holy [ __ ] dude
everyone looks like freddy krueger
that's major assault that woman's going
to oh yeah she's screwed and then
they're going to sue taco bell taco was
like god damn it let's get 20 mil that's
so weird 20 mil for me to burn your face
[ __ ] happen no no but it looks like
they're not
do you never know you're probably really
bad i think they're doing well b they're
sprinting to their car yeah that's
really bad
that's scary dude they're asking for
more than one million bucks in damages
yep
yeah yep taco bell's like all right
yeah just go ahead there you go
they just
whittle it down they go we'll give you a
hundred grand each oh no i bet the taco
bell they'll give you a meal yeah
man oh man oh man
does elaine maxwell can enjoy movies and
yoga after transfer to florida prison so
i guess there they moved your thousand
miles to a soft low security prison in
florida one where inmates enjoy movies a
running track and even yoga in the yard
what do you think about this
how many years did they give her
was it 20 or 30 let me see if i can find
it here yeah i mean because she's 60 now
yeah six-year-old 20 years yeah 20 years
wow yeah she's screwed i mean you know
she's still in jail so what do you want
to do put her in a cage i mean you know
well i guess compare do you think that's
evidence that she has some sort of
special treatment i mean compared to
something like i don't you know sammy
the solitary confinement whatever these
other guys who end up
in much uh less luxurious situations
it's a low security federal well because
this was she's not really a threat right
yeah she's a madame so i think it's a
little different yeah like el chapo gets
like
three minutes of sunshine yeah if that
so is that really hear about his son
when they captured his son you hear what
they did oh how they wouldn't let him
leave
like
they they shut everything down
yeah they well they caught his son
and then el chapo's the cartel
said oh okay
they said they put they attached they
went to all the soldiers families their
houses
and attached
dynamite to the propane tanks and said
if you don't let them go we're going to
blow up all your houses
and they let them go
they also shut down the road yes they
couldn't get out they did everything
right yeah did everything
crazy
so unless you guys got more stuff keep
it flowing here man you're [ __ ]
starting so
good fellas and lawn order actor another
uh guy who portrayed a gangster oh he
was great paul
died it's great
83 natural causes though 83 good run
good run good career
long jordan he was huge on the order
that was [ __ ]
was that not what he was on oh yeah for
a long time he's on there forever
remember ray leota was like paulie used
to slice the garlic so this would melt
right in my hand
i didn't know he's on law and order
oh yeah that's what we got start
well that's what he was known for before
i mean goodfell is so major though right
wow
what a movie that was
oh and i didn't realize it makes sense
that he was the father of oscar winning
actress mira scorpino i think sammy the
bull told me that that was that movie
was very close to the real thing really
yeah
yeah the garlic too
that's how it was done and so that's how
it was done that was i was causing
mustard i was a mafia yeah
they were good chess robot versus boy
knight takes pawn but i'll take your
finger yeah you see right here in this
video the robot gets bad no so he's
playing a robot uh-huh but the kid's not
supposed to
he's supposed to wait till the robot's
done so the robot just got stuck on his
finger and it broke his finger now do we
think the robot gets stuck
by like cabbage i know it's my job right
so i told you not to touch the [ __ ]
what's the problem with these [ __ ]
robots
damn but the kid came back the next day
and played it again
[Laughter]
wow
now chin thought this is going to be a
little too edgy and dark but just gonna
throw it out there did you guys see the
footage of the shark
biting the guy's finger off when he's
trying to get the hook out of its mouth
like a little shark but he catches a
shark yeah and then he's trying to get
the hook removed yeah truck bites his
finger off yeah that's not too dark for
us
we can't play stuff like that anymore
because we get flagged for anything
that's like bodily injured you can harm
can you react to it or not no we can
actually play for these guys
who just bites off his pinky this it's
such a depressing video i hate it
yeah i think it's one for the sharks
i agree with that
dude i can't get enough of this [ __ ]
listen to what he says after
and the kids warning him don't do it
oh he turns goddamn pinky
lost my goddamn pinky
but also oh my god
why did the shark do the alligator
they're not good
shark
and it got us thinking and wanted to
[Music]
like right away he knew it like but if
you're going to take one well it just
popped off i know oh for sure it popped
up
that's the one well for you you play the
guitar if you're me it's like ah [ __ ]
that for me it's a great story and a bit
on i dude yeah
blood comes out look at the shark's
mouth yeah man right now it was just
like i'll lose my pinky for a bit
[Laughter]
you know what to say again fellas if
this were to happen to me you tell
everyone it was a giant great you don't
tell us a small [ __ ] bluetooth could
have been his fingers could have been
his hand brandon saved us all he was
punching left his pinky out shark got it
great yeah great weather tiger anything
else depressing yeah megalodon really
well
our boy paul de gelder
gets his arm his leg is getting sawed
off by a bush great weather no
tigers he said yeah
and then and then he punched it and he
lost his hand because the shark bit his
hand off because they always tell you oh
i don't know they always tell you
but you got to punch the shark yeah and
tiger goes
okay
yeah it's like my joke you ever try to
punch underwater
yeah it's funny but you know it does
work apparently because i knew a guy in
high school got bit at stinson beach his
name was jonathan catherine um he got
bit on a surfboard and he was like
wrestling like that comes up from
underneath right bumps you off and
you're like in the water and he's trying
to like get a whole this thing has it's
his leg in its mouth and he's reaching
around for some place to grab
and he puts his hands
gills inadvertently that's what made a
release oh wow and was it a great white
it was a great white yeah
they say go for the gills or eyes where
was this stinson beach you could
probably look at it
jonathan catherine with a kill
oh no yeah those are great whites that's
great
yeah jonathan catherine stinson beat
shark attack it would have been like the
year 1998
that's great
c-a-t-h-r uh either i-n-e or as soon as
i met there it is oh you missed it jen
said uh shark attack if you go back hold
on yeah there you go
wow
wow
uh a great white shirt well bodyboarding
don't bodybo body born at 16 pacific
ocean along california coast did he lose
a leg or anything
no he has a scar opened on his legs but
he got back into surfing
and i was i um i don't know that the
saying bodyboarding might be inaccurate
my understanding was he was surfing and
he is a surfer uh he got back into
competitive swimming he wrote books
about it he went like wrote a tale and
wrote like a kid's book that's like it's
called don't fear the shark basically
saying like there's not a reason to
you know vilify sharks i hate when they
do that
they're just all these people they buy
sharks like it's not the shark's fault
yeah it is
[Laughter]
that is you go around getting
motivational dogs well we need to
conserve the sharks the thing bit the
[ __ ] out of you
would you would you go see a
motivational speaker who just says like
super yes
oh yeah yeah yeah that's what i want i
want the chaos he'll be like man [ __ ]
sharks
i was minding my business if i could rip
my leg off yeah
whoever tells you like you know it's a
good story it's horrible this thing
would have [ __ ] ate my face off go
around one leg advocating for shark fin
soup so he underwent seven hours of
surgery major muscle in his legs uh only
six at what i lost my pinky [ __ ]
he's kind of manly like lost my god damn
that's a man right there you're just
pissed dude like i should have been
[ __ ] with the sharky like you're
smart like god i told you [ __ ] i didn't
want to do it
you lose yourself
i get nine [ __ ] things right now i'm
now nine now i'm johnny
you guys are what you want to go down
this is why i don't want to go down
[ __ ] johnny nines i walk in there is
tom 10 and now and johnny and i and
shark bit my finger up you piece of [ __ ]
i wanted to [ __ ] take a piano when i
retired [ __ ] i don't want to be here
no you don't you you i told you i think
it was [ __ ]
what's worse can happen this
this
[ __ ]
johnny nines your johnny nines
well i'll tell you where i'm gonna be
putting my pinkies in the waters in
baltimore next week august 4th through
the 6th i'm in baltimore mcgoobies okay
baltimore maryland i've never been there
one of the very few cities i've never
been i've been to my goobies i've never
been involved i've never been to
baltimore ever first time
i'm gonna have my boy nate mccabe take
care of you oh yeah he's got you what's
your name dude
nate sneaks the prince of baltimore he's
got he's got you covered restaurants
where you want to go okay that'll be
good information yeah and i will be
doing the uh raylos dance all through
the streets that's baltimore august 4-6
and then chicago's august 26 one night
only friday the den theater in chicago
is the 26th at 7 30 p.m show in downtown
chicago den theater one night one show
only
and on the 27th is the thick boy tough
mudder the thick mudder 10 a.m heat
promo code is team brendan come run with
us limited capacity on this bad boy get
you some
well fakeboy.com daddy's at the austin
texas cap cities this coming for you oh
yeah thursday morning yes sir thursday
friday saturday
uh i am there i can't wait austin texas
i'll be hanging with my boy rogan on
thursday i got nashville tennessee
zany's august 26 27 i got specan
washington september 22 24
and uh we go from there it's gonna be
good boom is that it dude that's it
buddy all right love you guys bye